the cafe's become kind of assembly we
live in perilous times when it comes to
free speech and the threats are coming
from both the left and right so we're
going to open up those libel laws folks
and we're going to have people sue you
like you never get sued before the
president has threatened legal action
against the media and progressive
activists have used violence to shut
down campus speakers they don't like in
the Los Angeles Times former federal
prosecutor Ken white shreds the most
popular cliches used by would be censors
trying to make the rest of us shut the
hell up that's technically true but the
Supreme Court has ruled that those
exceptions are extremely limited it's
true that there are carve outs for libel
defamation through threats of immediate
violence and obscenity to page 108
paragraph 3 no jokes dealing with
flatulence excretion urination
ejaculation or other bodily function
also no paragraph 2 no use of the
so-called seven dirty words these are
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and [ __ ] but the fact is opponents
of free speech have greatly exaggerated
the limits to what we're allowed to say
we're irreverent to the point that loom
actually iconoclastic and with game
people hate speech including horrible
ugly and stupid statements is broadly
protected as Ken white points out even
outright bigotry isn't an exception to
the First Amendment point that is it is
just there might be a philosophical case
for this position but there's no legal
one the courts don't do cost-benefit
analyses on specific speech Act and if
the speech doesn't fall into a
prohibited category you can't stop it
this widely miss quoted line but Supreme
Court justice Oliver Wendell Holmes jr.
has often been used as justification for
censorship as white points out speech is
only prohibited if it's intended and
likely to provoke imminent lawless
action so if you see somebody getting
ready to throw a tomato knock the crap
out of would you seriously fact is that
over time the Supreme Court has only
expanded free speech even cases
involving videos of animals being
tortured where the Westboro Baptist
Church's demonstrations at military
funerals have yielded solid eight-to-one
majorities in favor of free speech if
today's calls for suppressing speech
teach us anything it's that we can never
take the First Amendment for granted
even if the Supreme Court is on our side
free expression will only continue to
exist for as long as we're willing to
make it ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]